lefty rodney ray who you know through
his career has been very solid against
these dodgy a lot of left-handed hitters
in this dodger lineup uh and robbie has
done well against those lefties the
dodgers now are in business first and
third and nobody out down the line and
right cole cal who's got it
what a catch
bets will tag and it's one nothing los
angeles but paul calhoun the buckeye and
valley native welcome to chase field
that's the kind of play that prevents
that crooked number here's aj pollock
the former diamondback who's off to a
hot start six for 12 and he's had good
numbers of course in this ballpark
swinging a fly ball to left field
way back and it is at the wall and gone
a home run aj pollock has returned home
with a two-run shot and just like that
the dodgers now have a three to nothing
lead for the last couple seasons the
highest strikeout to walk ratios in
baseball verlander is one and right
ahead of chris sale is ross stripling
eduardo escobar coming off a career year
last year when he knocked in 118 off to
a very slow start this year bringing a
line drive caught by chris taylor no
runs one hit
one left seeger who has consistently hit
the ball hard
so far in the first week
[Applause]
he has reached base in each of the first
six games turns on this ball lifts it
deep to right field calhoun's back and
seeger's gotten ray
a deep home run
and the dodgers lead four nothing
second home run in as many games corey
seeger is red hot so the bases are
loaded mellinger with a glorious
opportunity just out of a slump
bellinger on the ground is second
gobbled up by marte and cattell flips to
walker and that will end the inning so
the dodgers settle for one they'll leave
them loaded one out for could tell
martay who's single to start the
diamondback first
this is well hit to deep left field and
say goodbye it's over the wall for a
home run for cattell martay that's his
first and the d-backs are on the board
that's a jumbo jack that's number two in
the books and the first for the
diamondbacks leadoff man this year all
right here is callaway who fly to center
first time up a liner in the right field
and a diving catch made by mookie beds
oh is he fun to watch
he came sprinting in a dive and he
caught it just above the ground
back to back two out walks after he
started beginning with two strikeouts so
robbie has now walked six in three and
two thirds two one and two out now for
bellinger who's over two swinging a
ground ball to the second base side
and on to first with the throw is ahmed
the short stop to end the ending so i'll
go 6-3 on the right side taylor did the
job advancing the runner now seeger has
got a home run and is grounded out is at
the plate a little spinner off the end
of the bat pollock trying to storm will
as seeger's thrown out he gets an rbi
and the dodgers lead 5-1 accident field
hit a run scored fouled out and walked
there's a fly ball
into left center field and deep way back
and gone a home run
max muncie with an opposite field home
run that just kept on carrying and the
dodgers lead at 6-1 on muncie's third
still one-on-one out for arizona and
christian walker stands in
walker laces one down the line it's
headed for the corner
and escobar is on the run they're gonna
send them around third tony perez chica
weighs him home
and christian walker's got an rbi double
make it six to two
just a line shot
all the way down that little v
area right in front of the bullpen and
esquire is able to score easily two outs
now for carson kelly and a broken back
leader to right that's going to be a
base hit here comes a runner around
third walker no throw by bets and carson
kelly delivers a big two out hit and he
cuts the dodger lead in half it's now
6-3 nick tonight is over two he's
grounded out and he's lined to right
field
tomahawk bouncer to short long throw for
taylor
in time
what a play by chris taylor and he shows
off a strong arm there
shortstops love this because you're just
going to throw it as hard as you can but
you just make sure you keep it down and
then you trust your first baseman that
you're going to get that nice long hop
so it is pedro baez to come and try and
lock this thing down in the bottom of
the nine
maya's last year got his
first career save that's a fly ball to
right center field
the bets pulls in
very nicely so ahmed trying to make
things interesting with a man on and two
out here in the ninth inning if he can
reach arizona would get the tie and run
to the plate
one out away nick ahmed coming up
ahmed pops it up this should do it left
side of the infield chris taylor the
dodgers have started this road trip with
a three-game winning streak